et
le corps d'agnès a jamais été retrouvé
ça fait plus de vingt ans il faudrait
peut-être apprendre à faire le deuil de
votre fils ma fille a été assassinée par
maurice agnelet je ne peux pas laisser
l'assassin d'agnès en liberté je ne peux
pas
premier a été retenu au casino j'ai fait
mon voyage va regarder le feu comme ça
ça rend prise qu'est ce que vous voulez
je regarde moi par exemple j'ai posé des
questions sur vous vous savez je veux
pas croire tout ce que les gens disent
sur moi je vois ce qui met du mais je
peux pas racheter des parts pour
l'instant j'ai pas lu fondre votre
ennemi c'est fratoni seulement des
opérations de déstabilisation pour faire
tomber les casinos de la côte petit
avocat qui a pas les moyens de ses
ambitions pour vous les gens sont
vraiment que des larbins votre fille a
raison mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
tu peux plus travailler pour vous je ne
sois plus votre conseiller est toutefois
de ce type il est malsain il s'intéresse
qu'à ton argent je crois que j'ai une
idée qui pourrait intéresser fratoni
c'est vrai qu'en externe l'amitié à 3
millions ok si elle vote contre sa mère
je vous demande donc de voter pour le
renouvellement de mandat tu veux te
contre qu'est ce que tu fais à nice qui
je vote contre
en fermer la boutique une fois qu'on
aura signé maurice sera la seule
personne qui ont accès à mon compte
non pas que tu t'imagines que tu viens
de m'acheter la cette procuration ne
changera rien entre nous
je sais que maurice n'est pas l'homme
d'une seule femme
jamais demandé à être aimé mon camp je
vais pas jouer au mec amoureux juste
pour faire plaisir
je suis désolé j'avais pas me contenter
de ce que tu donnes ce type te rendras
malheureuse
je n'ai pas le droit de me laisser comme
ça sans nouvelles dans l'inquiétude de
savoir où tu es ce que tu deviens
je te demande pardon maintenant je suis
un sourire
un vrai